- To have a special life you
have to do special things.
That usually means
putting in the work and loving it.
(hip hop music)
Alexa, play Tee Grizzley,
I Remember.
- [Alexa] I Remember, featuring
YFN Lucci, by Tee Grizzley.
- The quickest and easiest way,
you're recording, right?
The quickest and easiest way
to get to do what you want,
while paying your bills,
is to start sacrificing
leisure and other things,
and start focusing on monetizing
the thing that you wanna do in the future.
Please factor in what the world's going
to be like in 2019 to 2025,
versus looking at what the
world was like 2009 to 2015.
Way too many decisions
by way too many people
are being made by factoring in the past
without anticipating the future.
(slow piano music)
I think Office is gonna be a
lot bigger than people think.
I saw, this, for corporate people
this is gonna make so much
sense to everybody in here.
Like, literally the most fascinating thing
to me about corporate America,
is the first 17 minutes of
a meeting are not useful,
because we can't get it on the screen.
Like, AirPlay is literally one of
the worst products of all time.
My prediction, and this is again a guess,
I'm surprised and I, my bet is
this Super Bowl or the next one,
I think that Apple, Google, or Amazon
should just give it away for free.
It's so valuable as a
razor, selling razor blades.
I just, the economics are so big
that I'm like fuck these
things are like nine bucks.
Like ship 'em to people, like I just,
I think during the Super
Bowl if they were just like
take one, like go to the website now,
that I think we're close
to full penetration.
(energetic electronic music)
(office workers chatting)
What's up everyone?
- I'm kind of in the
point where I'm deciding
between a bunch of
different possible careers.
How do you kind of know--
- You don't.
- Where to go with it?
- Or how do you start with that?
- The way you really win is by recognizing
that all four of you have
a substantial advantage
over me, which is you're half my age.
You take your advantages.
Some advantages are experience.
Some advantages are youth.
The fact that all four of the
jobs that you're thinking,
that you literally can
work at all four of them.
You know, maybe they won't be available
or things like them, like
I wanna be an architect,
a sports agent, and advertising,
and do my own start up snow cone business.
You could do all four and still be 30.
And when you're 20 or
22, 30, listen I always
say this, and if you listen to my content
I bring it up a lot,
'cause it was so profound.
My 30 year old cousin
Bobby, who I love very much,
was eight years older than
me when I came out of school
and he was the other
person in the liquor store,
I mean he was old, you know,
like 30 was like
(imitates bomb exploding).
I just remember, I was
like that's like a man,
and I'm a kid.
And so, now being 12 years
older than that, being 42,
looking at you characters,
you know it's funny
I smile because, the gift that I wish
I could give you is perspective.
Like, first of all, most of
the people that are giving
you advice either love you too much
or are looking backwards.
They either love you too much
or they're looking backwards.
- Loving you too much almost
always manifests into defense.
So your parents are almost
always gonna give you
the least upside advice, almost always.
And then number two, your uncle,
you have an older brother
whose best friend happened
to wearily always be your mentor,
and he's 11 years younger, he or she
is giving you advice based on 1996.
That's the problem.
I'm glad we spent some time.
- Appreciate you--
- Yeah ping me if you need me.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Oh, Gary.
- It's such a pleasure.
- Hello.
- How are you?
- Hello, is it you or is it Instagram?
- It's me, it's me, nope
this is not Instagram.
- It's Instagram, Instagram.
- See, nope this is real.
- Instagram.
(group laughing)
- Where we going, in here?
- Godzilla.
- Yeah okay, cool, is this Godzilla?
To be a recording artist that people,
like, to play Lincoln Center is special.
That's hard.
So to get there should be hard.
People are like I wanna
play Madison Square Garden.
I'm like, okay, let's take a step back.
How many people in the history of music
have played Madison Garden?
Thousands, probably tens of
thousands I don't really know.
But definitely not hundreds of thousands,
definitely not millions,
definitely not tens of millions.
There's 7.7 billion people on Earth now.
Over the course of the 50 years, 60 years,
we're talking about 30,
40, 50 billion people
and 10, five, eight, nine
thousand acts or people
have been able to play it.
I don't think people go practical.
Like the practical nature of it is,
it's almost impossible,
but people walk around
and think they're gonna be
a rapper or an entrepreneur.
Like it happens to everybody.
And so to have a special life
you have to do special things.
And that usually means putting
in the work, and loving it.
I could never do what I do,
I work 15, 16 hours a day, 17, 18.
I usually see him at 10:00,
11:00, 12:00 at night.
If I went to school tomorrow, high school,
I'd be tired by 11:30 A.M.
I used to drag through school,
by the time it'd get to 3:30
I was like dead, 'cause I hated it.
So you can't put in the
hours unless you love it.
That's why I believe loving
it leads to the most success.
Because I think somebody else
loves what you don't love,
that you're doing for money.
Thus, they'll be more successful,
'cause they're gonna do it
for 19 hour.
- True.
- Now there's talent.
- Yes.
- You may not love singing,
and you open up your mouth
and you sound like fuckin'
Whitney Houston, that's real.
You may not love, there's
athletes, absolutely I know them,
who are not passionate about their sport,
but they were born six foot
10, and very coordinated.
So it happens, it happens.
But I think that's the rarity.
(affirming)
- Hi guys, I finally made
it to Gary B's office,
and I met a lot of his amazing people.
The team that makes everything work
and I must say that you
are one of my mentors,
and I look up to you in so many ways.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for inspiring the world,
with every minute, and
every second, and every word
that comes out of your mouth.
Including the swear words.
(laughs)
- Hey everybody, one life,
do something with it.
- Please say hi to Nigeria.
- Nigeria I love you.
(blows kiss)
- Yay.
- Coming soon, going to
Ghana again on another trip.
And I'm gonna stop in
Nigeria on this one, so
we gotta talk about that as well.
- So I have a new song and
it's called LLS so just sing,
♪ LLL, where you dig? ♪
- Yes. (cheers)
- Yes.
That wasn't bad.
- Yes!
- I was actually, I'm stunned right now.
My friend.
- Thank you so much.
- Such a pleasure.
- Great to see you, I'll see you soon.
- See you.
- All right.
- How did you stumble into
the, you know it's funny,
when I started pushing the word gratitude,
it used to be thankful.
I used to say to my mom
all the time on the phone,
"I'm so thankful, I'm so thankful,"
and somewhere along the
line my vocab got better
and I understood that the
form was actually gratitude
and we talk about kindness earlier
when they weren't on live.
How did you stumble into the terminology
of asking, like when did it click for you?
When did it start coming
out of your mouth?
- About 10 years ago, I mean,
Michael Beckwith for one book
which is The Law of
Attraction, and I realized
that you know, asking
is a form of gratitude.
When you ask, you're allowing
someone to give back to you
but nobody does it, and
then I looked at gratitude.
- It makes so much sense to
me, because, it's my favorite.
(energetic electronic music)
- [Interviewer] Per talent
and personality wise,
like if someone's looking to grow a team,
who are those players from your experience
that will just bring a
team sort of full circle
and get the job done?
- People that are
disproportionally self aware,
and have the ability to be
the bigger man and woman,
when the going gets tough, no question.
Self awareness matters, like
if you think you're great
at video and nobody else does,
and you're beating your head into it,
that's going to eventually
become a problem.
And then what happens in organizations
is people have different agendas.
And so when an agenda and an agenda match,
are you able to be the bigger person?
Super important.
Those two things matter.
Like I know what I'm good at,
I know what I'm not good at.
I empower people based on the things
that I don't think I'm as good at.
And then, you know, for me,
what I really respect from
the leaders that work here
is their ability to be like,
okay we're having a conflict,
let me level up, and try
to be the bigger person.
Let's not make this
personal, let's communicate.
And as you see what's
happening in society,
sometimes we have that,
and right now we don't.
And everything's just fighting.
There is no dialogue.
- [Interviewer] No respectful
discourse and like--
- We just don't have it right now.
- It's OK to disagree.
- Everyone's on tilt.